PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
ON THE WAY TO LONDON, KIM WAS
CONFRONTED ABOUT TALKING
BEHIND PEOPLE'S BACKS...
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT
EVERYBODY IN THIS HOUSE,
AND THIS IS NOT VENTING.
THIS IS YOU BEING OBNOXIOUS.
LIKE I'M SORRY.
AND LIKE SOMETIMES
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
BUT THE CONFRONTATIONS KEPT
COMING WHEN THE GIRLS HAD
THEIR FIRST ENCOUNTER
WITH THE PAPARAZZI...
NO, SORRY.
OKAY, GUYS, GET YOUR PICTURE.
AND DESPITE
A FIERCE PHOTO SHOOT,
LISA TURNED SOME JUDGES OFF...
DON'T YOU THINK SOMETIMES
LISA IS TOO IN YOUR FACE,
TOO MISS PERSONALITY?
...AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
JAYLA.
FIVE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT WAS A VERY,
VERY SURPRISING
AND SHOCKING ELIMINATION.
WILL LISA AND JAYLA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
LISA WAS SOMEONE
THAT I THOUGHT
WOULD BE IN THE TOP THREE
FOR THE WHOLE TIME
I'VE BEEN HERE.
JAYLA.
WHEN THEY CALLED
JAYLA'S NAME,
OUR MOUTHS DROPPED LIKE, "WHAT?"
IT'S OKAY. BYE-BYE.
IT'S SCARY JUST TO KNOW
THAT SHE CAN DO SO GOOD
AND SHE CAN GO HOME,
WHICH MEANS, YOU KNOW,
ANY OF US CAN GO HOME
LIKE THAT.
HOW AMAZING WOULD THAT BE
IF YOU AND I WERE IN
THE TOP THREE TOGETHER?
AAH!
LIKE IF YOU WON,
I'D BE SO HAPPY, DUDE.
SERIOUSLY. NO, SERIOUSLY.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE LIMO
WAS COMPLETELY BLOWN
OUT OF PROPORTION.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT
EVERYBODY IN THIS HOUSE,
AND THIS IS NOT VENTING.
THIS IS YOU BEING OBNOXIOUS.
WE'VE PUT OUR PROBLEMS ASIDE,
WE'VE DEALT WITH THEM.
AND WE ALSO
CARE ABOUT EACH OTHER
AND WANT TO HELP EACH OTHER OUT.
WE STARTED...
WAY DOWN...
WELL, YOU STARTED
A LITTLE HIGHER THAN ME.
BUT WE STARTED PRETTY LOW.
BEING IN LONDON MAKES THINGS
MORE INTENSE.
THE COMPETITION GETS STIFFER,
THE PICTURES ARE ALL BEAUTIFUL,
AND AFTER AWHILE, IT JUST
KINDA BOGGLES YOUR BRAIN.
I TOLD YOU,
GOD GOT PLANS FOR ME.
HE SURE DOES.
TYRA MAIL.
YOU GUYS, COME IN HERE
SO WE CAN READ THE MAIL.
"FIND OUT THE PECKING ORDER
AT 7:00 A.M.-- TYRA."
WHAT IS PECKING ORDER?
THAT'S LIKE
EXCELLENT, GOOD, FAIR, BETTER.
BAD, WORSE.
I'M NOT SURE I LOVE THAT.
HI, GUYS, MY NAME IS JASON.
I'M A FASHION STYLIST,
AND I TEACH AT
THE LONDON COLLEGE OF FASHION.
TODAY, WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS TEACH YOU ALL ABOUT POSING.
WE'RE GONNA GO AROUND LONDON
TODAY AND HAVE
A LOOK AT THE SCULPTURES.
WHAT YOU'VE GOTTA REMEMBER
IS WHEN THESE GUYS ARE POSING
FOR THE SCULPTURE, THEY HAVE
TO STAY IN POSITIONS
AND HOLD POSITIONS
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
AS A TOP MODEL,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL
FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO CONCENTRATE
ON THE PHOTOGRAPHER
DURING THE SHOOT.
LET'S HEAD OFF TO THE BUS
AND HAVE A DRIVE AROUND LONDON
AND CHECK IT ALL OUT.
THAT IS EROS,
THE GOD OF LOVE.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
IT'S LIKE ONE LONG CURVE
RIGHT DOWN
TO THE END OF THE FOOT.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF YOU GUYS
HAD TO POSE FOR THAT,
HOW LONG IT WOULD--
HOW LONG DO YOU RECKON
YOU COULD STAND TIPTOEING
WITHOUT MOVING?
I NEVER THOUGHT BEFORE
TO LOOK AT A STATUE AND GO,
"WHY IS IT LIKE THAT?"
IT'S ALL BECAUSE
OF HOW THEY'RE POSED.
IF YOU FALL OUT OF YOUR POSE
JUST THE TINIEST BIT,
THEN YOU CAN
COMPLETELY RUIN SOMETHING.
OKAY, LET'S GET OUT
AND HAVE A LOOK AROUND
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN FIND, OKAY?
WE'RE WALKING IN REGENT PARK,
AND WE RUN INTO
THIS BEAUTIFUL STATUE,
AND IT'S MISS J. STANDING UP
IN FULL-ON FREEZE MODE.
HEY, J. VERY GOOD.
SEE HOW FOCUSED HE IS?
HE'S NOT FAZED
BY MY TALKING ABOUT HIM.
I'M SURE HIS EYES
AREN'T EVEN COMING DOWN.
WELL, FOR TODAY'S CHALLENGE
YOU WILL BE JUDGED
ON STATUESQUE POSES,
FOCUS, AND CONCENTRATION.
SO, GIRLS, YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ALL THE DISTRACTIONS AROUND YOU.
WHOEVER KEEPS THEIR POSE
THE BEST IS GONNA WIN.
I WILL CHOOSE ONE WINNER,
AND THE WINNER IS GONNA GET
A HUGE SHOPPING SPREE.
QUITE SIMPLE.
SINCE WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU
POSE LIKE STATUES...
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU
LOOK LIKE STATUTES.
WHAT?
THE WARDROBE
FOR THIS CHALLENGE
IS FULL ON BODY PAINT
SO WE COULD LOOK LIKE STATUTES.
I FEEL ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO
IS TO GET UP ON THE PEDESTAL.
I GONNA PRESENT YOU
WITH THESE TWO SILVER TRAYS.
I WANT YOU TO CHOOSE
YOUR FIERCEST, STRONGEST POSE
YOU CAN GIVE ME.
COME UP
WITH YOUR POSE.
CHOOSE YOUR FIRST POSE.
YOU READY
FOR YOUR FIRST POSE?
I'M GONNA TIME YOU FOR
A MINUTE, OKAY?
WE'RE COMPETING
FOR A SHOPPING SPREE.
BALANCE IT. YOU READY?
I REALLY WANT TO WIN
THE CHALLENGE
BECAUSE THAT'S PROBABLY
THE COOLEST PRIZE THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN IN A CHALLENGE YET.
GIVE IT A POSE.
I GET UP THERE,
AND I'M THINKING LIKE, OKAY,
I CAN SO DO THIS, AND THIS IS
GONNA BE MY CHALLENGE.
AAH! AAH!
FOCUS, FOCUS.
(coos)
PIGEONS ARE
THE DIRTIEST BIRDS
YOU COULD POSSIBLY FIND.
I HAVE A PIGEON
ON MY HEAD.
YES, YOU DO, BABY.
BUT THEY ALL ARE TOILET-TRAINED,
DON'T WORRY.
OHH! OHH!
PIGEONS ARE FLYING RATS.
THEY EAT RATS.
THEY'D PROBABLY EAT ME
IF THEY COULD.
WHEN BRE REALIZED
THAT THEY WERE PIGEONS,
SHE LOST IT A BIT.
EE!
(coos)
I KIND OF NEEDED TO STEP UP
MY GAME, SO I PUT IT ALL
OUT OF THE MY HEAD.
FANTASTIC.
NIK-- SHE DIDN'T BLINK.
SHE FROZE HER POSE PROPERLY.
I LOVE
THE DOUBLE-HEADED PIGEON HAT.
IT'S BRILLIANT.
I DIDN'T REALLY MIND
THE PIGEONS BY THE END.
IT FELT KIND OF NICE WHEN
THEY WERE SCRATCHING MY HEAD.
THAT WAY, YOU REALLY HAVE YOU
HAVE NO DISTRACTIONS NOW.
YOU CAN'T SEE A DAMN THING.
KIM LACKED
A BIT OF IMAGINATION
WHEN IT CAME TO THE POSES.
JAYLA-- SHE LOOKED LIKE
SHE WAS CONCENTRATING TOO HARD.
OHH!
I JUST STARTED CRYING.
I MADE A FOOL
OF MYSELF.
BUT, SERIOUSLY,
I JUST DON'T LIKE
HUGE BIRDS ON TOP OF ME.
(coos)
FANTASTIC. ALL POSERS DONE.
THIS HAS TO BE
THE FUNNIEST CHALLENGE EVER.
THAT WAS
LITERALLY HUMILIATING.
I AM HUMILIATED.
NICOLE COMPLAINS
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SERIOUSLY,
I NEVER WANT TO DO THAT AGAIN
WITH THOSE NASTY THINGS.
HER VOICE
IS SO ANNOYING.
IT'S SO SHARP AND ALARMING.
I WAS IN TEARS--
STREAMING DOWN MY FACE
AND LIKE, "AAH!"
MY HAIR IS ALWAYS AT ENDS
WHEN SHE TALKS,
AND I DON'T FEEL
LIKE IT'S A CONVERSATION.
(screaming)
I WAS SERIOUSLY FREAKING OUT.
THOSE BIRDS WERE LIKE--
WHEW.
TODAY, THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
GETS TO GO ON A SHOPPING SPREE.
AND THE SHOPPING SPREE
IS WORTH...
$15,000.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
CHILD.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, SHE GETS
TO TAKE TWO FRIENDS
ALONG WITH HER.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
I AM GOING TO GO FOR...
OHH!
OKAY. NIK.
YEAH!
THANK YOU.
OH, IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE.
I'VE NEVER WON ANYTHING
HERE BEFORE.
I'VE KIND OF BEEN LIKE
THE GIRL ON THE BOTTOM
WHEN IT COMES TO CHALLENGES.
SO IT KIND OF FEELS GOOD
TO BE THE ONE TOP RIGHT NOW.
SO WHO ARE YOU GONNA TAKE?
I'M GONNA TAKE BRE
AND... JAYLA.
ALL THE GOLD GODDESSES.
OH, IT MUST BE
TOUGH.
SO YOU'RE GONNA SHOP
TILL YOU DROP, BABY.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE, IF YOU LEAVE
THIS SWEATER ONE MORE TIME,
I PROMISE, I'M GONNA
THROW IT IN THE GARBAGE.
ALL DAY, NICOLE WAS
GETTING ON MY NERVES.
I'M NOT REALLY FEELING
WELL TODAY.
I'M A LITTLE STRESSED.
I WANT GO TO SLEEP.
YOU WANT TO WORK OUT MAYBE?
WORKING OUT
IS SO OVERRATED.
NICOLE IS VERY LOUD
ALL THE TIME,
AND I THINK SHE'S
VERY INCONSIDERATE.
OH, THESE BEDS ARE
SO MUCH MORE BOUNCY
THAN THE ONES AT HOME.
"AT HOME." OH, MY GOD!
I JUST CALLED
THAT HELL HOUSE OUR HOME.
YEAH, I TAKE THAT ONE BACK.
I'M ALREADY AGGRAVATED,
AND SHE JUST BUILDS
AND ADDS TO THAT FRUSTRATION.
(clicking tongue)
I KNOW SHE THINKS I'M LOUD
AND OBNOXIOUS.
I DON'T CARE.
JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE HAVING A BAD DAY
AND YOU'RE GRUMPY AN ANGRY
ALL OF THE TIME,
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I HAVE
TO STOOP DOWN TO YOUR LEVEL.
LIKE I'M STILL GONNA
HAVE FUN AND BE HAPPY.
GUYS, THERE'S A TYRA MAIL.
YOU, UP.
BRE, UP.
"HAVE YOU EVER FELT LIKE
YOU WERE BEING FRAMED?
TYRA."
I'M EXHAUSTED AND IT'S LIKE
1:00 IN THE MORNING.
I DON'T EVEN SPEND TIME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE DAY'S
GONNA BE LIKE THE NEXT DAY.
I JUST GO TO SLEEP.
SO WE MAKE A GROCERY LIST
AND EVERYBODY GETS SOMETHING
FROM THE STORE.
BUT THEN
I LOOK AT MY GROCERY LIST.
LOOK AT MY RECEIPT,
CHECK TO SEE
IF I GOT EVERYTHING I NEEDED.
WHY IS MY CEREAL BAR BOX
ALREADY OPENED?
HEY, THAT WAS NICE.
WHO DID THAT?
WHO GOT FIRST DIBS
ON MY STUFF?
AND I'M SO HEATED.
DON'T TOUCH MY FOOD.
THE PRESSURE IS RIDICULOUS
AT THIS POINT,
AND BRE'S FOOD OBVIOUSLY
IS IMPORTANT TO HER.
I MEAN, WHEN PEOPLE START
MESSING WITH, YOU KNOW, FOOD
AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
IT'S GONNA GET REALLY UGLY.
I POURED OUT ALL OF NICOLE'S
CANNED SODAS.
I'VE BEEN DISRESPECTED,
BUT THIS WAS JUST TOO MUCH.
(laughing)
OH, GOD.
BRE, IS THAT REALLY NECESSARY?
GO.
YOU'RE SO SKETCHY.
BRE IS LIKE,
"YOU GO BACK TO YOUR ROOM,
AND YOU GO TO SLEEP NOW
AND DON'T COME BACK IN HERE."
AND AT THIS POINT, YOU KNOW,
I FEEL STUPID
BECAUSE I'M LIKE GETTING
BULLIED AROUND.
I WAS DOING JUST FINE
UNTIL YOU WEASELED
YOUR WAY IN HERE.
BUT YOU-- YOUR MIND WANDERS,
THINKS TOO-- TOO MUCH.
YOU HAVE TO FIND OUT.
OF COURSE I DO.
AND I WAS LIKE,
"TELL ME WHAT IS GOING ON.
LIKE TELL ME WHAT YOU TOOK."
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
I PUT JAYLA'S DIRTY SOCKS
UNDER NICOLE'S BED."
AND I WAS LIKE, "WHY?"
YOU'RE GONNA FIND SOMETHING
BETTER IN THE MORNING.
I DON'T REALLY
WANT TO BE IN THE DRAMA.
I FEEL LIKE I JUST KINDA
HAVE TO FOCUS ON MYSELF.
I HAVE ENOUGH THINGS
TO WORRY ABOUT.
GOOD NIGHT.
I'M JUST GONNA TRY
AND BE CORDIAL
AND GET ALONG WITH BRE
AS BEST I CAN
UNTIL ONE OF US IS ELIMINATED
AND THEN I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT HER ANYMORE.
I WON A CHALLENGE,
AND SO THIS MORNING IS THE DAY
WE GET TO GO ON OUR SPREE.
GOOD MORNING.
WE WALK DOWNSTAIRS,
AND WE WERE GREETED BY
A HARRODS' ROLLS-ROYCE.
AND YOU DIDN'T EAT
THEM GRANOLA BARS, RIGHT?
OKAY, WHAT IS THIS
ABOUT THE GRANOLA BARS?
I KNEW IT WAS NICOLE.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
IN THE HOUSE.
THERE'S NO GHOSTS.
THERE'S NOTHING.
TO MAKE A LONG STORY SHORT,
I SNUCK IN THE ROOM
AND EMPTIED OUT
ALL OF HER RED BULLS THAT
SHE JUST BOUGHT FROM THE STORE
AND LEFT THEM EMPTY.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE THE ENERGY
TO GET MAD.
I JUST DON'T HAVE
THE ENERGY TO EVEN BE AROUND
THESE PEOPLE ANYMORE.
I WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
AND I FIND THAT
MY ENERGY DRINKS ARE GONE.
TWO OF THEM ARE OPENED
AND EMPTY IN THE BATHROOM.
I JUST WANT THESE PEOPLE
TO LEAVE. GO HOME.
BACK IN L.A., BRE WAS
THROWING INSULTS AT ME
AND BASHING MY CHARACTER
IN THAT LIMO.
YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY ABOUT EVERYBODY,
AND I KNOW THAT, SWEETHEART.
I KNOW.
LIKE I'M SORRY AND LIKE
I JUST DON'T LIKE--
SOMETIMES I JUST DON'T KNOW.
AT THIS POINT, I'M REALLY UPSET
THAT I APOLOGIZED IN THE LIMO.
I'M JUST STUPID AND LIKE
I JUST LIKE SAY THINGS
FOR COMIC EFFECT.
I THINK THAT BRE IS LIKE
PRETTY JEALOUS OF ME,
AND I THINK SHE'S JEALOUS
OF KIM BECAUSE KIM'S DOING
REALLY WELL NOW.
WE NEED TO CONCENTRATE ON
HAVING A GOOD PHOTO SHOOT.
SO WE'RE NOT THE ONES
WHO GET... BOOTED.
("Spring" from
Vivaldi's "Four Seasons" plays)
HELLO, GIRLS,
AND WELCOME TO HARRODS.
BY APPOINTMENT
IS A V.I.P. SERVICE
FOR THE ULTIMATE SHOPPING
EXPERIENCE.
NIK, AS THE WINNER,
YOU HAVE A $10,000
SHOPPING SPREE,
AND YOUR PERSONAL SHOPPER
TODAY WILL BE RAYMUNDO.
JAYLA AND BRE, YOU HAVE
$5,000 SHOPPING TO DO TOGETHER
WITH YOUR ASSISTANTS
LAURA AND SIMONE.
SO LET'S GET SHOPPING.
IF YOU SEE ANYTHING CUTE,
JUST TELL ME.
OH, DEAR.
IS THAT WHAT YOU LIKE?
YES.
THIS IS NICE.
DON'T LIKE THAT?
NO.
THAT'S SO POLICE, GIRL.
THAT IS GORGEOUS.
THEY'RE NICE.
YEAH.
WHAT ABOUT BAGS?
BAGS?
HOW MUCH IS THAT ONE?
REGULAR PRICE IS $1,400.
IT'S KINDA COOL JUST
TO BE LIKE, "I WANT THIS ONE
AND THIS ONE,
AND I THINK I LIKE THIS ONE."
IT MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE MADE IT.
I DON'T WANNA BE AVERAGE.
I WANT TO BE FIERCE.
I KNOW.
HONEY, YOU'RE SHOPPING WITH ME.
YOU'LL BE FIERCE, TRUST ME.
WANNA HAVE A LOOK
AT MARC JACOBS?
YEAH.
I HATE THIS.
OKAY, I'M THINKING
WE'VE GOT A FEW T-SHIRTS.
WE'VE GOT AT LEAST THREE PAIRS
OF JEANS.
THIS IN A SMALL.
IT IS DEFINITELY RETAIL THERAPY.
ARE WE TAKING THIS ONE?
YEP.
ALL OF THE STRESS THAT WAS
GOING ON TODAY JUST KIND OF
LIFTED OFF OF MY CHEST,
AND I JUST FELT LIKE I WAS IN
A DIFFERENT PLACE FOR ONCE.
NIK, DID YOU SEE
YOUR HANDBAG?
YES, I DID.
MY FAVORITE THING I GOT
WAS THIS PURSE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE BRAND.
I JUST KNOW IT COSTS
A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
HONEY, I THINK WE'VE ACTUALLY
DONE REALLY WELL.
WE GOT BETTER STUFF
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT SINCE WE HAVE TIME...
OH, WE HAVE TIME.
WE'RE GONNA GET MORE STUFF.
SO AFTER THE SHOPPING SPREE,
WE WENT TO OUR PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE KIM AND NICOLE
ARE WAITING FOR US.
HEY.
HIS BOOBS LOOK FABULOUS.
MY BOOBS LOOK
FABULOUS?
YEAH, I KNOW, THEY'RE GREAT.
THERE'S A REASON I'M WEARING
THIS LITTLE CRAZY TOP,
BUT I'M GONNA TELL YOU
ABOUT THAT IN A SECOND.
TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE ACTUALLY
DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR OLAY QUENCH,
A NEW BODY LOTION FROM OLAY.
NOW BACK IN THE DAY,
MODELS USED TO SIT
FOR HOURS AND HOURS FOR ARTISTS
AS THEY PAINTED
AND SCULPTED THEM.
NOW, YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA HAVE
TO USE THAT SAME CONCENTRATION
TODAY AS WE RE-CREATE CLASSIC
ART WITH A MODERN TWIST.
NOW BEHIND ME, THE SETUP
THAT'S GOING UP
IS "THE BIRTH OF VENUS."
AND, ACTUALLY, KIM, YOU ARE
GONNA BE "THE BIRTH OF VENUS."
DO YOU KNOW THAT PIECE OF ART,
BY THE WAY?
YEAH.
NICOLE, ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THE
"GIRL WITH THE PEARL EARRING"?
SO THAT'S GONNA BE YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NIK, YOUR CHALLENGE--
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE
THE "VITRUVIAN MAN,"
WHICH IS STRAIGHT ON,
ARMS OUT, LEGS OUT.
SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CONFRONT THAT FACE ON POSE.
BRE, YOU'VE GOT THAT LITTLE
SUBTLE SOMETHING GOING ON
GOING UNDERNEATH THERE.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THE "MONA LISA," ALL RIGHT?
JAYLA, DO YOU KNOW WHO
"WHISTLER'S MOTHER" IS?
YEP.
IT'S ALL
ABOUT PROFILE AND NECK,
AND YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT NECK SO MUCH,
SO THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TODAY.
SO DON'T YOU GET THIS?
THIS IS MY MODERN INTERPRETATION
OF MY CLASSIC ART.
FEEL IT?
ALL RIGHT.
I'M EXCITED, AND YOU GUYS
SHOULD BE SUPER EXCITED BECAUSE
I'VE GOT A VERY SPECIAL GUEST
WHO'S GONNA INTRODUCE
AN EXTRA, EXTRA SPECIAL GUEST.
TWIGGY, COME ON OUT HERE.
THIS IS THE MAN
WHO CHANGED MY LIFE.
HE TOOK MY FIRST PHOTOGRAPH
IN 1966.
HIS NAME IS BARRY LATEGAN.
AS YOU KNOW, I'VE TALKED
ABOUT HIM ALL THROUGH THE SHOW.
THE GUY WHO PHOTOGRAPHED ME
IS A GENIUS.
HE'S A MAN CALLED BARRY LATEGAN,
WHO STILL WORKS IN LONDON.
AND I HAVE TO SAY,
THE HAIRCUT WAS VERY IMPORTANT,
BUT BEING PHOTOGRAPHED
BY SOMEBODY AS BRILLIANT AS YOU,
IT DID CHANGE MY WHOLE CAREER.
YOU ARE ALL GOING TO BE
REPRESENTING IN A MODERN SENSE
THE WAY BEAUTY HAS BEEN
LOOKED AT IN THE PAST.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LOOK AT YOU
LIKE A ROW OF TOMATOES
WHERE YOU ALL LOOK ALIKE.
YOU GIRLS DON'T EVEN KNOW.
MOST GIRLS DON'T GET
THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE SHOT BY A WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER SUCH AS BARRY.
THE FIRST PERSON THAT
APPROACHES ME IS KIM.
SHE'S LIKE, "TELL ME YOU'RE
GONNA PAY FOR NICOLE'S DRINKS."
SHE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT.
I WAS LIKE...
I DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT IT.
OKAY, BUT WHY ARE YOU
MAD AT ME? I'M JUST SAYING--
I'M NOT MAD AT YOU.
I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT?
HELLO, HI."
I THINK YOU SHOULD MIND
YOUR BUSINESS.
I DON'T WANNA GET INTO IT.
ALL RIGHT, I JUST--
YOU KNOW... I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S JUST OTHER PEOPLE'S STUFF.
IT SUCKS WHEN PEOPLE
TOUCH YOUR STUFF, RIGHT?
YEAH, I MEAN, I GUESS SO.
YEAH, I THINK SO, TOO.
YEAH, THAT'S WHY I WANNA SAY
Y'ALL COULD JUST REPLACE IT
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
NO.
OKAY, THEN FINE, THEN DON'T.
KIM WAS TRYING TO MEDIATE,
BUT SHE GOT HERSELF
STUCK IN THE MIDDLE OF IT,
SO SHE KIND OF DREW HERSELF
INTO THE PROBLEM
THAT SHE WAS TRYING TO FIX.
SERIOUSLY, KIM, I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE PLAYING
BOTH SIDES OF THE FENCE.
I'M PLAYING NO SIDES
OF THE FENCE.
YOU DON'T TRUST ME,
AND YOU CAN TRUST ME.
AAH!
I JUST NEED A CORNER.
ALL RIGHT, TAKE A CORNER.
DON'T SAY ANOTHER WORD
TO ME.
PLEASE DON'T.
DON'T SAY ANOTHER WORD
TO ME.
PLEASE DON'T.
I JUST ASKED BRE A SIMPLE
QUESTION, AND SHE BLEW UP.
AND I WAS TRYING TO MEDIATE
AND JUST TRY NOT HAVE
ANY MORE CONFLICTS.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
SHE WAS JUST TRYING TO PROVE
A POINT, THAT'S ALL.
WHAT POINT, THOUGH?
YOU DON'T TOUCH SOMEONE
ELSE'S STUFF.
YEAH, BUT I DON'T THINK--
I'M NOT SURE NICOLE DID, DUDE.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN YOU'RE
A LITTLE BIT DISTRACTED
BY EMOTIONAL STUFF,
AND I'M TRYING TO FOCUS,
BUT BRE'S ANGER IS JUST A BIT
OUT OF CONTROL.
SHE JUST LOSES IT
AND LIKE GETS VERY ANGRY,
AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT SCARY.
HEY, GIRLS,
LOOK, I BROUGHT OUR ARTWORK.
TODAY WE'RE TAKING
A WHOLE BUNCH
OF FAMOUS PAINTINGS,
AND WE'RE DOING THEM OVER,
BUT IN A MORE MODERNIZED STYLE.
SO, KIM, WE'RE DOING THIS
PHOTO SHOOT FOR OLAY'S
NEW QUENCH BODY LOTION
BECAUSE THEY WANNA SHOW
HOW IT KEEPS THE SKIN
MOISTURIZED ALL DAY.
THE PAINTING THAT
I'M PORTRAYING
IS "THE BIRTH OF VENUS,"
SO I AM COMING OUT
OF THE SORT OF SEASHELL
ON THE BEACH SORT OF THING.
LOOKING DREAMY MORE DOWN,
THOUGH.
LOOKING DOWN THERE,
THAT'S IT.
NOW BRING YOUR HAND BACK
WHERE IT WAS.
NOW SPREAD YOUR FINGERS AGAIN.
THAT POSITION IS GREAT.
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL
WITH THE HAND.
RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
A CATCHER'S MITT.
I HAVE TO REALLY WORK ON
MY HAND AND SOMEHOW FIND A WAY
TO MAKE MY HANDS USEFUL
AND ELEGANT AND BEAUTIFUL
IN THIS PICTURE.
NOW TAKE YOUR HAND
ACROSS MORE.
JUST KEEP HOLD OF THE FABRIC.
YOU CAN'T ALLOW
THE COMPETITION
TO GET INTO YOUR HEAD
WHEN YOU'RE MODELING,
AND UNFORTUNATELY,
SHE COULDN'T FIND ANY GRACE
WITHIN HER STANCE.
THANK YOU.
ALL THE BEST.
JAYLA, YOU'VE BEEN STUDYING
YOUR PICTURE?
I'VE SEEN IT.
YOU'VE SEEN IT?
I DEFINITELY THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A PIECE OF CAKE.
I'VE LEARNED FROM JUST SITTING
IN A MAKEUP CHAIR,
JUST SITTING THERE, STARING OFF
INTO SPACE AND NOT MOVING.
I WANT YOU TO WORRY ABOUT
YOUR POSE AND HOW YOU POSE IT.
SO IF ANYTHING, I WOULD GET
ON A CHAIR
AND START WORKING SOME THINGS.
THIS IS THE TIME WHEN YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
I'M ALREADY POSING.
EXCELLENT.
I'M TRYING TO COPY
FROM THE PHOTO,
AND MY HANDS ARE KIND OF LIKE
WAVING SORT OF TWO-DIMENSIONAL.
I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS
A VERY ELEGANT GESTURE HERE.
THAT'S NICE THERE,
GOOD.
I LIKE THAT, YES.
KNEES TOGETHER, GOOD GIRL.
SHE USED HER ARMS
IN THE MOST GYMNASTICALLY
COORDINATED WAY.
SHE WAS COMPLETELY IN TOUCH
WITH EVERY EXTENSION
OF HER BODY.
I'VE GOT IT, THANK YOU.
"WHISTLER'S MOTHER"
HAS KIND OF A BORING,
DEPRESSING LOOK TO IT.
BUT I HAVE TO MAKE IT LOOK
MODERN AND SEXY.
THAT'S MY CHALLENGE WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
TAKE THE ELBOW BACK
SO I SEE MORE OF THE ARCHWAY.
THAT'S NICE THERE,
YES.
DON'T CROSS THE LEGS.
KEEP PLAYING
WITH THE HANDS LIKE THAT.
YES, THAT'S GOOD, THAT'S IT,
GOOD GIRL, GOOD GIRL.
LOVELY THERE, EXCELLENT.
JAYLA BROUGHT THE MODERNITY
TO "WHISTLER'S MOTHER."
SHE CAPTURED THAT BEAUTIFULLY.
HEAD DOWN,
PUSH THE CHIN FORWARD.
YOU THINK I SHOULD?
NO, MNH-MNH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
IN THIS SITUATION.
DUDE, YOU ALREADY INVOLVED
YOURSELF IN THE SITUATION.
YOU DID EXACTLY
WHAT I SAID NOT TO DO.
YOU CONFRONTED HER HERE.
WHO CONFRONTED WHAT?
BRE THOUGHT THAT NICOLE
TOOK A GRANOLA BAR.
KIM ENDED UP
TELLING JAY WHAT WAS GOING ON.
SO HE KNOWS WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE HOUSE.
THIS IS LIKE
THE WHOLE AGE-OLD STORY OF
LIKE, YOU KNOW, LIKE THE MOVIE
"SHOWGIRLS," OR WHATEVER,
WHEN SHE PUSHED THE GIRL
DOWN THE STAIRS
'CAUSE SHE WANTED TO GET
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WHEN COMPETITION HEATS UP,
PEOPLE START TO GO CUCKOO.
I THINK WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
WHEN YOU GET GIRLS TOGETHER,
THERE ARE GONNA BE FIGHTS.
BUT I THINK YOU NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO PUT THAT STUFF ASIDE.
I FEEL LIKE SHE MIGHT
HAVE DONE THIS JUST BECAUSE
IT WAS RIGHT BEFORE
OUR PHOTO SHOOT.
SO LIKE I JUST WANT
TO PROVE LIKE THIS ISN'T LIKE
GONNA AFFECT ME AT ALL.
LET'S FOCUS ON
GETTIN' YOU ONTO SET.
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO WORRY ABOUT THIS.
I'M PROUD THAT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING THIS AFFECT YOU.
LET'S JUST SEE WHERE BARRY IS.
WHAT'S THAT SMELL?
OIL OF OLAY BODY QUENCH.
SMELL IT.
I LIKE THAT,
IT SMELLS REALLY GOOD.
IT MOISTURIZES YOU
ALL DAY LONG.
MY PICTURE THAT I'M TRYING
TO PORTRAY IS
THE
"GIRL WITH THE PEARL EARRING."
I HAVEN'T READ THE BOOK,
BUT I KNOW THE PICTURE.
LOOKING HERE.
STEADY THERE.
TAKE THE SHOULDER FORWARD.
THAT'S NICE THERE.
BRING YOUR CHIN
ONTO YOUR SHOULDER.
I TOTALLY CLOSE OFF THE
SITUATION WITH BRE
BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT I MESSED UP MY CHALLENGE,
AND I NEED TO HAVE A GOOD
PHOTO SHOOT.
WHOA, WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE WATCHING NICOLE.
SHH.
TAKE THE SHOULDER FORWARD.
THAT'S IT.
LOVELY THERE.
LOVELY LIKE THAT.
NICE, NICOLE.
NICOLE DID A MUCH BETTER JOB
THAN SHE HAS IN PAST WEEKS.
AND SHE DIDN'T LET
THIS WHOLE KAFUFFLE
WITH HER AND BRE
AFFECT HER PHOTO SHOOT.
WITH ALL OF THE INTERFERENCE
GOING ON AROUND YOU,
YOU WORKED TO THE CAMERA.
EXCELLENT.
IT'S THE POISE OF CONFIDENCE,
YES?
THAT'S IT. LOVELY.
KEEP THAT POISE.
LOVELY.
GOOD.
LOVELY THERE, YES.
JUST LET THE FIRST FINGER
GO UP A LITTLE MORE.
DON'T FORGET
THAT LITTLE SMIRK THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
MY THING IS,
WHEN YOU AT WORK,
A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS
CAN BE GOING ON IN YOUR LIFE.
YOU JUST GOTTA LET IT GO.
IT'S BEEN WEIRD ALL DAY.
AND I DECIDE
I'M GONNA CONFRONT BRE
BECAUSE I'M DONE
WITH MY PHOTO SHOOT
AND SHE'S DONE WITH HERS.
BRE, I FEEL LIKE WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
WE SHOULD TALK RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU DID TAKE IT, I'D JUST
LIKE APPRECIATE YOU
REPLACING IT OR PAYING FOR IT.
I'M NOT REPLACING IT.
AND IF YOU THINK
I TOOK ANYTHING OF YOURS,
I DIDN'T TOUCH ANYTHING.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHO STOLE
THESE GRANOLA BARS
SHE SPEAKS OF.
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
YOU LIKE STEALING MY THINGS.
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT.
STEALING IS TAKING IT,
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO TOOK IT,
AND YOU NEVER SEE IT AGAIN.
I DIDN'T STEAL IT.
YOU KNOW WHERE IT IS.
YOU DRANK IT. YOU STOLE IT.
THAT'S STEALING, BRE.
I'M LIKE, THERE'S TWO
TWO EMPTY CANS IN THE BATHROOM.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO DO NOW?
I WANT YOU TO PAY FOR IT.
I'M NOT.
SO NOW WHAT DO WE DO?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
I DON'T GET IT.
YOU'RE JUST
KIND OF A MEAN PERSON.
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE WRONG.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS WACK
'CAUSE I NEVER TOUCHED
ANY OF YOUR THINGS.
I'M NOT REPLACING IT.
I'M NOT.
OKAY, WHATEVER.
IF THAT'S WHAT KIND
OF PERSON YOU ARE,
THEN AT LEAST I KNOW IT NOW.
SHE'S LIKE THE SPAWN
OF THE DEVIL OR SOMETHING.
FREAK.
I DON'T LIKE NICOLE.
I DON'T BELIEVE HER STORY.
IF I HAVE TO HEAR ONE MORE WORD
ABOUT THAT RED BULL,
SHE'LL BE WEARING IT TONIGHT.
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY FOUR WILL CONTINUE
ON IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I'M PROBABLY GOING HOME
FOR WHAT I DID TO NICOLE.
I KNOW I DID IT AND I KNOW
I DON'T REALLY LIKE HER.
SO I DON'T REALLY
FEEL BAD FOR DOIN' IT.
YOU NEED TO STAY IN THE GAME.
OH, MY GOD,
WHAT WOULD I DO IF YOU LEFT?
WHAT WOULD I DO?
DUDE, IT WOULD BE SO BAD.
I COULD BE GOING HOME,
AND I REALLY THINK THE PERSON
WHO SHOULD GO HOME IS BRE
BECAUSE BRE HAS A REALLY MEAN,
VICIOUS PERSONALITY.
WE MIGHT AS WELL
JUST TOAST TO THE NIGHT.
WHAT A DAY IT'S BEEN.
I'M STAYING AWAY
FROM BRE.
TRYING TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
STAY AWAY FROM PEOPLE
I DON'T TRUST.
AND PEOPLE I DON'T TRUST
PRETTY MUCH JUST EQUALS BRE.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR EIGHTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE PRIZES THAT I SAY
EVERY SINGLE WEEK, BUT AS
WE GET CLOSER TO THE END,
THEY BECOME MORE REAL.
THE FIRST IS
A MODELING CONTRACT WITH
TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A COVER
OF "ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE,
WHICH HITS STANDS
IN FEBRUARY, 2006.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
THANK YOU.
HI, GIRLS.
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
OUR FABULOUS
DIVALICIOUS RUNWAY COACH.
HELLO.
FASHION ICON TWIGGY.
HELLO, GIRLS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
OUR GUEST JUDGE IS
MR. BARRY LATEGAN.
BARRY LATEGAN DISCOVERED TWIGGY.
HE DID HER FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
AND PUT HER ON THE MAP.
GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO YOUR FUTURE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT, THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE
AND WE'LL DETERMINE WHICH ONE
OF YOU SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
BRE, YOU'RE FIRST.
WHAT'S WRONG?
I THINK THAT YOU-- OKAY,
I DON'T KNOW YET.
ALL RIGHT, BRE, SO THIS WEEK
YOU LEARNED ABOUT CONCENTRATION.
WE WANT YOU TO GIVE
A STOIC POSE,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO HOLD THAT FOR ONE MINUTE,
STARTING NOW.
♪ OH, JESUS... ♪
♪ LORD ♪
(blows noisemaker)
HAVE YOU GOT A HEADACHE?
BUBBLES!
(wolf whistles)
(blows noisemaker)
CAN I GET A KISS?
I GOT ME TEETH FIXED.
THAT THANG UP ON HER BOOTY.
SWITCH IT AND KISS IT.
WORK IT, BABY.
GOT IT.
CRAZY.
IS THAT STOIC?
(belches)
♪ STOIC ♪
I KNOW YOU LIKE
THIS BOOTY, BARRY.
BARRY, I KNOW YOU WANT
MY BOOTY.
WELL, I DIDN'T WANT
TO STOP, BUT IT'S TIME.
(laughs)
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO EVALUATE YOU.
FIRST IS NICOLE.
SO YOU HAD TO SHOW HOW WELL
YOU DEAL WITH CRAZINESS
WHILE POSING.
I THINK YOU DID
A PRETTY GOOD JOB, NICOLE.
YOU HANDLED YOURSELF
PRETTY WELL,
YOU KNOW,
GOOD, CONFIDENT.
YOUR POSES WERE RATHER ODD,
THOUGH.
AND YOU KNOW HOW I FELT
ABOUT YOU THE OTHER DAY.
AT THE PIGEON CHALLENGE.
AAH! AAH!
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF FEAR OF BIRDS.
AAH!
A COUPLE OF SEASONS AGO,
EVA HAD THE BIGGEST FEAR
IN THE WORLD OF SPIDERS,
AND SHE DID IT AND SHE BECAME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AND SHE'S EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL.
AND MY FEAR IS DRAG QUEENS,
SO I'M JUST...
FEAR OF SELF!
ANYWAY... OKAY.
NICOLE, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU HAD TO REINTERPRET
CLASSIC ART AND MAKE IT MODERN.
SO YOU HAD TO RE-CREATE THE
"GIRL WITH THE PEARL EARRING"
BY VERMEER.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
FOR ME, THAT PAINTING IS
THE LOOK IN THAT GIRL'S EYES,
AND I LOVE THE LOOK
IN YOUR EYES.
AND I THINK IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
THANKS, TWIGGS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO GET OUT OF HER.
BUT I'LL BE HONEST,
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO GET THIS.
YOU WERE GIVING...
BUT YOU HAVE TO JUST RELAX
AND JUST KIND OF LIKE HAUNTING.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS NIK.
YOU HAD TO POSE, THEN HOLD IT
AND SHOW CONCENTRATION
AND HOW WELL YOU HOLD
YOUR CONCENTRATION.
FOR ME, NIK,
YOU DID THE BEST JOB OF ALL.
AS FAR AS THE POSES WERE
CONCERNED, THEY REALLY
ACTUALLY LOOKED
PHOTOGRAPHICAL AND BEAUTIFUL.
YOU JUST LOOKED GOOD.
EXCEPT WHAT WAS THIS?
STOIC?
STOIC MEANS VOID OF EMOTION.
OKAY, I JUST ASSUMED THAT
IT WAS PART OF LIKE OUR TEACH
AND OUR CHALLENGE OR SOMETHING.
SO SHE WAS LIKE,
HOLD THE BIRDS,
HOLD THE BIRD SEED!
ALSO, NIK WON THE CHALLENGE...
FANTASTIC.
...THIS WEEK...
WELL DONE, SWEETHEART.
...WITH THE BIRDS.
ALL RIGHT, NIK, SO YOU
HAD TO RE-CREATE
"THE VITRUVIAN MAN"
BY LEONARDO da VINCI.
THE COLOR'S BRILLIANT.
THE LEGS
LOOK AMAZING.
THEY WERE VERY SYMMETRICAL
MOVEMENTS.
SHE HAD TO BE
IN PERFECT ANGLE TO HER BODY.
SHE KEPT COMPLETELY CONSISTENT.
THE REASON WHY
I CHOSE THIS FOR YOU
IS BECAUSE, WHAT ARE YOU
ALWAYS DOING?
ALWAYS DOING THAT.
BUT YOU'RE FACE ON
AND YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
SEE!
QUITE FRANKLY, YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS PICTURE
AND REALIZE HOW
GORGEOUS YOU LOOK STRAIGHT ON.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE BRE.
FOR YOUR CONCENTRATION
CHALLENGE, YOU STARED
INTO THE HEAVENS.
YOU STARED RIGHT INTO
THE BOSOM OF JESUS.
ALL RIGHT, BRE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT WHERE
YOU HAD TO RE-CREATE
THE "MONA LISA,"
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
BRE, I LOVE THAT YOU LOOK
LIKE MONISHA SHAQUESA.
LUCRETIA.
MONISHA LUCRETIALISA.
BRE, I THINK YOU'VE
REALLY DONE A GREAT JOB
WITH THIS SHOT.
YOU LOOK LIKE
AN AFRICAN PRINCESS.
YOU BROUGHT REGALNESS
TO THE SHOT.
MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOU WERE THE BEST ONE
AT CAPTURING THE MOOD
OF THE ARTWORK,
BUT YOU DISPLAY
CLASSIC SHOWGIRL SYNDROME,
MEANING YOU MAY BE
INSECURE AROUND NICOLE,
AND THAT INSECURITY, AT TIMES,
MAY MAKE YOU GO FOR THE JUGULAR.
I WAS VERY PROFESSIONAL
AND WHATEVER
WAS GOING ON AT HOME,
I WASN'T TALKING
ABOUT IT AT WORK.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY BEHIND ME
COULD VOUCH FOR THAT,
INCLUDING NICOLE.
SO YOU THINK YOU WERE PERFECT?
YOU DON'T TRUST PEOPLE,
AND YOU CAN TRUST ME.
AAH!
I JUST NEED A CORNER.
ALL RIGHT,
TAKE YOUR CORNER.
DON'T SAY ANOTHER WORD TO ME.
PLEASE DON'T.
YES, I DO.
BECAUSE I DON'T CARRY MYSELF
LIKE THAT.
AND I TOTALLY DISAGREE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY,
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG, BRE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS SAID,
BUT KIM CAME UP TO ME
AND WAS JUST LIKE,
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT
ALL MORNING, SO--
THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
I SAID, "IF YOU DID THIS,
THEN, YOU KNOW,
"IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL,
JUST REPLACE IT.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL."
BUT DID YOU NOT SAY
THAT YOU AND NICOLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT IT?
NO, I SWEAR ON MY LIFE
I NEVER SAID--
NICOLE, WHAT HAPPENED?
'CAUSE YOU SEEM TO BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS.
SOMETHING WAS STOLEN FROM ME.
LIKE IT WAS REALLY DUMB,
IT WAS A FEW ENERGY DRINKS,
AND I TOLD BRE
IF SHE COULD JUST REPLACE
WHAT SHE TOOK,
IT WOULD BE FINE.
IT KIND OF WENT FROM THERE,
I GUESS.
BRE, DID YOU TAKE
SOMETHING FROM NICOLE?
YES.
WITHOUT ASKING?
UM, MY STUFF WAS TAKEN.
I THOUGHT THAT NICOLE TOOK IT,
SO I TOOK NICOLE'S STUFF.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT
YOU DID A SORT OF RETALIATION
OFF OF AN ASSUMPTION.
OR EVEN IF SOMETHING IS REAL,
RETALIATING IS VERY JUVENILE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU A STORY--
WHEN I WAS 18, 19 YEARS OLD,
I WAS WITH ELITE MODELS,
AND THEY HAD
AN APARTMENT FULL OF
EIGHT OR NINE, TEN GIRLS.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
ONE OF THE MODELS
WAKES ME UP AND SAYS, "BITCH,
YOU STOLE MY ALARM CLOCK."
I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
I STOLE YOUR ALARM CLOCK?"
SHE ACCUSED ME,
AND SHE WAS WRONG
AND SHE WENT THROUGH MY THINGS.
I DIDN'T RETALIATE.
IT WAS JUVENILE,
AND I DID TAKE HER STUFF.
AND IT WAS WRONG.
ALL RIGHT, BRE,
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS KIM.
YOU HELD THAT FACE.
YEAH, 10 OUT OF 10.
SHE DIDN'T CRACK, DID SHE?
YOU DID NOT CRACK ONCE.
ALL RIGHTY,
SO YOU HAD TO RE-CREATE
"THE BIRTH OF VENUS"--
BOTTICELLI.
WOW, A FEMININE ICON.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
FACE FOR ME IS A LITTLE BIT SAD.
IT HAD TO BE.
I PUT HER THAT WAY.
I ASKED HER TO GO DREAMY.
I ASKED HER TO THINK ABOUT
HER MOTHER, ABOUT HER BOYFRIEND.
WELL...
NO WONDER SHE WAS SAD.
THAT'S THE COMBINATION
OF IT.
THERE YOU GO.
KIM, I THINK
WHAT YOU BROUGHT TO THIS
IS A MODERN POP SORT OF VERSION
OF THIS PICTURE.
AND WHAT I LIKE ESPECIALLY
IS THE FACT YOU DECIDED TO
WEAR THE SAME JEWELRY TONIGHT
AS YOU DID IN THE PICTURE.
VERY INSPIRING.
DID YOU STEAL THE JEWELS?
NO, I BOUGHT THEM.
YOU LIKE PAID FOR 'EM?
YEAH,
I REALLY LOVE THEM.
I DON'T KNOW, I LOVE THEM.
'CAUSE MODELS
USUALLY STEAL STUFF.
AS WE'VE LEARNED.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ENERGY DRINKS
ON THE BACK THERE?
MODELS ALWAYS STOLE THE SHOES
FROM FASHION SHOWS, THE RINGS.
WELL, I THOUGHT ABOUT IT,
BUT, YOU KNOW...
VERY HONEST.
FOR ME, JUST KIND OF WORK
ON YOUR HANDS BEING
A LOT SOFTER.
I KNOW,
I REALLY TRIED THIS TIME, BUT...
I JUST WANT TO GO.
IN LOOKING AT YOUR FILM,
IT WAS INTERESTING.
'CAUSE IT
STARTED OFF LIKE AMAZING,
AND THEN THERE WAS THIS CHUNK
IN THE MIDDLE
THAT YOU LOST IT.
IT WAS LIKE GREAT BEGINNING,
GREAT END, AND BLAH BLAH BLAH
IN THE MIDDLE.
I MEAN,
I FELT MYSELF GETTING TENSE
AND I SHOULD HAVE ASKED TO HAVE
LIKE A SECOND
JUST TO LIKE, YOU KNOW...
ALL RIGHT. THANKS.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE JAYLA.
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA, SO YOU HAD
TO SHOW HOW
MUCH CONCENTRATION YOU HAVE.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE MUCH.
YOU DID THE WORST.
YEAH, YOU WERE FAR TOO CONSCIOUS
OF WHAT'S
GOING ON
AROUND YOU.
HERE'S A FUNNY BUNCH.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE EXERCISE.
ALL RIGHTY,
SO YOU HAD TO RE-CREATE
"WHISTLER'S MOTHER"
BY WHISTLER.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
HMM, BEAUTIFUL.
YOUR PROFILE IS GREAT.
LOOK AT THE SENSE OF POISE,
OF HOLDING
HER NECK AND SHOULDERS.
JAY SAID YOU DID A GREAT JOB
WHILE ON SET,
BUT YOU GAVE ATTITUDE
WHEN HE TOLD YOU TO PRACTICE
ARCHING YOUR BACK.
HE FELT YOU BLEW HIM OFF
WHEN HE ASKED YOU TO PRACTICE.
JAYLA, YOU'VE BEEN STUDYING
FOR YOUR PICTURE?
I'VE SEEN IT.
YOU'VE SEEN IT?
I WANT YOU TO WORRY ABOUT YOUR
POSE AND HOW YOU POSE YOU IT.
SO IF ANYTHING,
I WOULD GET ON A CHAIR
AND START WORKING SOME THINGS.
THIS IS THE TIME
WHEN YOU FIGURE IT OUT.
I'M ALREADY POSING.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING THAT
YOU WIN MORE WITH HONEY
THAN YOU DO WITH VINEGAR.
DO YOU GUYS NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE ALWAYS
BEING WATCHED ON PHOTO SHOOTS?
LIKE PHOTOGRAPHER,
MAKEUP ARTIST, HAIRDRESSER,
THE ASSISTANT-- LIKE EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IS
WATCHING YOU
AND EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IS TALKING.
OKAY, THANKS, JAYLA.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND AFTER THAT,
I'LL CALL YOU BACK
AND ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THANKS.
WE LEAVE PANEL AND BRE
PRETTY MUCH GOES
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
SHE IS SO MAD AND SO ANGRY,
AND SO SHE STARTS
TO TAKE IT OUT ON KIM.
YOU COULDN'T TELL
THE TRUTH TO SAVE YOUR... LIFE.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THAT WAS THE TRUTH.
I SAID--
DID SHE NOT COME
UP TO ME AND SAY THAT...
SHUT UP!
DID SHE NOT COME UP TO ME
AND SAY THAT?
BRE, YOUR ANGER'S WHAT'S
GETTING YOU IN TROUBLE.
STOP IT NOW.
YOUR ANGER IS WHAT'S GETTING
YOU IN TROUBLE EVERY TIME.
NICOLE, FOR REAL, STRAIGHT UP,
WHAT I DID WAS WRONG.
STRAIGHT UP.
KIM CAME TO US BEFORE
I EVEN HIT THE ROOM.
'CAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
CONFLICT, AND I ASKED YOU--
KIM, YOU DON'T NEED
TO SAY ANYTHING.
IT'S NOT EVEN WORTH IT, BRE,
'CAUSE YOUR ANGER ALWAYS
GETS YOU IN TROUBLE,
AND YOU'RE THE ONE LYING.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT THE POSSIBILITY OF ME
GOING HOME TODAY IS ABOUT 96%.
YOU WILL NOT WIN
THIS COMPETITION BECAUSE
YOU ARE AN UGLY PERSON.
YOU HAVE AN UGLY
PERSONALITY.
TELL ME WHY NO ONE ELSE SEES
THIS "UGLY PERSONALITY" BUT YOU.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO SEES IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU'RE
A LIAR.
I HAVE NEVER--
ARE YOU KIDDING?
IT IS NOT EVEN WORTH IT
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE LIAR.
IT'S NOT EVEN WORTH IT
TRYING TO--
YOU'VE PROVEN THAT YOU'RE
THE LIAR IN THE SITUATION.
LOOK AT ME.
I DID SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY WRONG.
AND GOD DON'T LIKE UGLY.
HE DON'T LIKE IT.
I DEFINITELY FEEL
EXTREMELY BETRAYED BY BRE.
YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
WE WERE FRIENDS.
I ALWAYS MAINTAINED
A LOYALTY TO HER.
I NEVER TALKED ABOUT BRE
BEHIND HER BACK.
BRE IS SOMEONE THAT
I DON'T KNOW ANYMORE.
I LOVE YOUR PERSONALITY.
I DO.
THANK YOU.
I-- I FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
IT'S TIME FOR DELIBERATIONS.
FIRST UP, JAYLA.
SHE DIDN'T DO VERY WELL
KEEPING HER COOL TODAY.
WE MADE HER LAUGH.
JAYLA IS DEFINITELY A MODEL,
SHE TAKES GORGEOUS PICTURES,
BUT SHE'S FADING FOR ME.
I'LL WHISTLE AT
"WHISTLER'S MOTHER" AGAIN.
(whistles)
I SAY SHE'S IN.
NIK.
AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE COMPETITION,
SHE WAS NOT ON THE TOP THREE
OR FOUR OF MY LIST,
AND EVERY WEEK,
SHE HAS GOT HIGHER AND HIGHER.
THIS HAS BEEN A GREAT WEEK
FOR NIK.
THE SILENT GIRL IS FINALLY
COMING OUT OF HER SHELL.
SHE TOOK DIRECTION
FINALLY, AND SHE WENT
IN THE STRAIGHT DIRECTION,
STRAIGHT ON.
NICOLE.
SPEAKING OF CUTE AND SWEET...
(wails)
I THINK NICOLE TAKES
A GREAT PICTURE,
NOT A GOOD PICTURE.
I THINK SHE LOOKS
LIKE A MODEL TO ME.
SHE'S IN.
NICOLE IS ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT WAS BORN TO BE A MODEL.
MODEL, YES,
SPOKESPERSON, I DON'T KNOW.
KIM.
I'VE LIKED KIM
FROM THE BEGINNING
MAINLY BECAUSE SHE'S SO QUIRKY
AND DIFFERENT.
IS SHE REALLY EDGY?
IS SHE REALLY INTERESTING,
COOL AND DIFFERENT,
LIKE AN OMAYRA?
I DON'T THINK THAT KIM HAS
REALLY GIVEN ME
ANY AMAZING PICTURES.
KIM'S BLACK-AND-WHITE
WAS FIERCE.
HER FACE IS MORE SUITED
TO OUTDOOR CLOTHING,
TO MORE CASUAL--
I SEE MODELS ON A REGULAR BASIS,
AND I CAN IMAGINE SEEING KIM.
BRE.
SHE WAS
A BLACK MODEL REPRESENTING
A TRADITIONAL IDEA OF BEAUTY
THROUGH
A RENAISSANCE-LOOKING LADY.
THIS PICTURE OF BRE IS
THE PRETTIEST PICTURE
IN THIS WHOLE BUNCH.
SEE, I'M WONDERING
WHETHER SHE'S THINKING,
WHERE IS MY ENERGIZER DRINK?
I THINK IT WAS
ACTUALLY A GRANOLA BAR.
WAS IT A GRANOLA BAR?
WHAT HAPPENED HERE EARLIER
WAS VERY UPSETTING.
IT WAS JUST DISTRESSING.
DESPITE THE OPPORTUNITY
GIVEN TO HER
TO WALK AWAY FROM THIS,
SHE DECIDED TO ACTUALLY
TURN IT,
LIKE A SORT OF ALL-OUT WAR.
I THINK IT'S JUST
A LITTLE TOO LATE
FOR A BEAUTIFUL MOMENT, BRE.
FIVE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS STAND
BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FOUR PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE FOUR PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL...
NIK.
NIK, THIS PICTURE SHOWS THAT
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL STRAIGHT ON,
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO HIDE.
BE SURE AND REMEMBER THAT
AND BELIEVE IT.
OKAY.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
JAYLA.
JAYLA, YOU TOOK A BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE THIS WEEK.
BUT I THINK YOU HAD
A LITTLE ATTITUDE WITH MR. JAY.
I'M SORRY.
SO YOU LEARNED
THAT YOU GOTTA BE NICE
TO EVERYBODY BECAUSE THE WORD
GETS BACK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL IS
THE
"GIRL WITH THE PEARL EARRING,"
NICOLE.
CONGRATULATIONS,
THIS PICTURE IS BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
BUT I WANT YOU
TO LEARN SUBTLETY.
YOU DIDN'T REALLY HAVE SUBTLETY
WITH YOUR FILM.
JUST THAT...
SO PRACTICE THAT IN THE MIRROR.
OKAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
WILL BRE AND KIM
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL I DO NOT CALL MUST
IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND GO BACK HOME.
KIM, THIS COMPETITION IS
GETTING TOUGHER
AND TOUGHER EACH WEEK,
AND THE JUDGES LOVE YOU.
THEY LOVE WHEN YOU WALK
INTO THIS ROOM.
THE ENERGY THAT YOU HAVE,
THAT YOU'RE DIFFERENT.
BUT THE POTENTIAL THAT WE SEE
INSIDE OF THIS ROOM,
EVERY NOW AND THEN
IS AMAZING IN A PHOTO,
BUT A LOT OF TIMES,
IT'S LACKLUSTER,
AND SOMETIMES IT'S ALL RIGHT.
WE DON'T SEE CONSISTENCY
IN YOU.
BRE, YOU KNOW WHY YOU'RE
STANDING HERE, AND IT'S NOT
EVEN SO MUCH THAT YOU
RETALIATED ON SOMEONE ELSE,
BUT IT'S HOW YOU HANDLED
YOURSELF IN THIS ROOM.
YOU STOOD UP HERE AND SAID,"
"I'M PROFESSIONAL,"
I'M THIS AND THAT.
I DIDN'T SEE ANY OF THAT.
AND I THINK YOU LEARNED
A BIG LESSON ABOUT RETALIATION.
BRE, DO YOU WANT TO GO HOME?
NOT AT ALL.
YOU'RE NOT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS, KIM.
THANK YOU.
EVEN THOUGH, YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN ELIMINATED,
I KNOW THAT I'VE BECOME
A REALLY GOOD MODEL
THROUGH THIS PROCESS,
AND I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH,
MORE THAN I EVER THOUGHT
I'D EVEN LEARN.
IT'S ALWAYS HARD WHEN YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU LOSE TO SOMEONE
WHO HAS BETRAYED YOU.
THAT'S HARD FOR ME, BUT, UM,
YOU KNOW, I'M GONNA GET PAST IT,
AND, UM, THIS CAN ONLY
MAKE ME STRONGER.
I'LL MISS CERTAIN PEOPLE.
I'LL MISS NICOLE,
BUT MOST OF ALL, REALLY LIKE
I'LL MISS THE MODELING.
I GREW
TO SERIOUSLY LOVE MODELING,
AND I WANT TO CONTINUE WITH IT.
I'VE LEARNED, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING I KNOW ABOUT MODELING
FROM THIS COMPETITION.
I STARTED WITH NOTHING
AND I CAME OUT WITH GREAT SKILLS
AS A MODEL.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS GET CAUGHT UP IN
FRANTIC LONDON GO-SEES.
YOU GOT YOUR PORTFOLIO HANDY?
I'M SO SORRY,
I LEFT IT IN MY CAR.
PERFECT, EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT.
THAT'S AWFUL.
BUT IS THE CITY BIG ENOUGH
FOR BRE AND NICOLE
WHEN THEY'RE FORCED
TO SPEND THE DAY TOGETHER?
I'M SORRY, ME AND NIK WANT
TO GO TOGETHER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?